[Music]
the US's first major storm Left Behind
picturesque Ice Creations and
opportunities to play in the snow but as
officials said on Monday this storm was
and is very dangerous I have the very
sad news to report
that in addition to the 13 confirmed
deaths yesterday the Erie County
Department of Health medical examiner's
office has confirmed an additional 12
deaths bringing the total for the
blizzard to 25 deaths county-wide
that number is expected to go up not
just in New York state but across the
country
as rescue crews struggle to reach both
residents and drivers trapped during the
blizzard
New York state was already trying to
recover from a blizzard in early
December when this last storm hit
historic storms are no longer historic
to us that's become a way of life in our
state and that's results of climate
change as you see see extreme weather
events all over our country but all of
us in state and County local government
know we had to prepare for the next big
one the storm forced U.S airlines to
cancel thousands of flights meaning
hundreds of thousands of Travelers
Nationwide have to wait and wait to get
to their destinations
while in South Carolina a frozen pipe
that ruptured has put that State's
largest Food Bank temporarily out of
business all of that food is underwater
and then all the food in our
refrigerator freezer that we served we
had to take all of it out it's it's all
over water
meteorologists say temperatures
Nationwide should rise during the week
making it easier for the ice and snow to
melt where residents of the Buffalo area
that break in the weather can't come
quickly enough another 30 centimeters of
snow is in the forecast through Tuesday
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera